هناك المستشفيات منذ سنه كنت قد تحدثت عن
قطاع الدعم عن ثمانيه عشر مستشفى في شمال
غرب سوريا ما بين ريف حلب وريف ادلب ثلاثه
عشر مستشفى منهم يعملون بشكل تطوعي منذ
سنه الى الان لم تدخل اليهم المساعدات
الطبيه اذا نحن نتحدث عن قروب نفاذ
الامدادات الطبيه والمستودعات التي كانت
تستخدمها النقاط الطبيه والمستشفيات في
شمال غرب سوريا مع اعداد المصابين
المتزايده التي تصل الى المستشفيات
والنقاط الطبيه يمكن الحديث عن مشفى عفرين
المركز المشفى العسكري في مدينه عفرين
والذي كان عليه الثقل الاكبر بالاونه
الاخيره بعمليه نقلها المصابين من الزلزال
وترقيم العلاج في تلك المنطقه كريدورات
المشفى
وامتلات على بكره ابيها كانت هناك
اداره المشفى باخراج من تلقى العلاج الى
الى العرائط اكثر اكثر امنا بعيدا عن
المشفى لانه هم يحتاجون الى مساحه اخرى
لاعطاء اعطائها للمصاب اخر هناك جثث كانت
على بوابه المشفى قدمت من جنديرس لم
يسعفهم من حظ مسعفون ان يدخلوهم الى
المشفى لتلقي العلاج كانت قد وافتهم
المنيه على على الطرق الواصله لذلك هناك
نوع من دعني اختصر الكلام بيوم القيامه
جميع المصادر وشهود العيان الذين نحاول
توثيق الارقام او الحوادث منهم جميعهم
يستخدمون هذا اليوم وكانه يوم القيامه
المنازل او الاحياء المهدمه المدنيون
الذين يستخرجون احياء قد يكون محالفه من
حظ بالوصول الى النقاط الطبيه ومنهم من
توافيه المنيع الحاله النفسيه للجميع قد
تكون صعبه ولكن الامل الذي ينبعث من تحت
الركام مع اخراج اي طفل يبكي او اي امراه
او اي شخص ينادي لعائلته هذا ما خلق لدى
الجميع فرصه للامل للعمل واستخراج والحفاظ
على ما بقي من الشعب السوري